à l'est du loiret la montée des eaux
provoque des débordements localisés en
vigilance jaune c'est technicien rivière
ont plus de 300 km de cours d'eau à
surveiller et avec les précipitations à
venir ils ne sont pas inquiets enfin
pour l'instant on sait pas du tout
alarmant par rapport à la crue de juin
2016 on peut voir sur les les débits que
les débits sont vraiment très inférieurs
à ceux de 2016 donc pour l'instant c'est
c'est correct ça se tamponnent bien par
rapport aux seuls les seuls sont pas
grands jets d'eau comme ça a pu l'être
en 2016 cette crue hivernale n'a rien
d'exceptionnel comparée à celle de 2016
qui est dans toutes les têtes
un peu plus loin les techniciens
constate l'efficacité de plusieurs
ensembles de prairies qui font office de
tampon
il ya vraiment une corrélation entre
artificialisation de la vallée et risque
inondation donc nous notre objectif
c'est justement de redonner ce côté
naturel à la vallée est ainsi préservé à
les secteurs qui sont vulnérables ont
favorisé les écoulements ici on préserve
alors les secteurs à fort enjeu comme
les lotissements les habitations la
restauration des champs d'expansion dans
les différentes valide sera l'un des
programmes d'action d'une structure
unique
elle verra le jour en 2010 neuf avec la
fusion de plusieurs syndicats de
rivières alors l'intérêt de travailler
tous ensemble sur le bassin c'est
surtout d'avoir une vision vraiment
global d'ensemble où on peut travailler
sur l'ensemble des communes ya plus de
250 communes qui sont concernés sur le
bassin du loin et plus de 250000
habitants
donc c'est pouvoir mener des actions d
les zones de source ou on peut par
exemple ralentir les inondations afin de
réduire aussi les
les accidents sur l'agglomération
montargoise l'agglomération de nemours
par exemple la vigilance est maintenue
jusqu'à samedi
dès la fin des précipitations les sols
devrait se désengager progressivement